oyez oyez chers visiteurs aujourd'hui
batel de casse tête avec toi avec toi
avec toi non tourtois broken et toi
aussi
ok d'accord j'ai chopé des castels qui
sont identiques à chauffer bah en fait
c'est t34 est que j'avais et il ya la
rousse qui ont sorti des casse-tête qui
nous a envoyé ce exactement les mêmes
mais en couleur un chopper larousse
labrune larros la plante n'importe quoi
le wiki temps choisi deux dans le tas
différents ferrand
et avec ça et avec les deux tu choisis
on essaye de les résoudre et où on voit
si on me met des handicaps ou pas mais
je suis pas pressé bon dans ces petits
casse-têtes le mot ouais ouais bah moi
la géométrie ça me parle pas non plus
parce que c'est pas parlé une semaine
ok alors j'en choisis de celui-là il est
rigolo mais je sens qu'il est trop
difficile
on va partir sur celui ci d'accord tu
veux le groupe ti je veux bien petit non
je le gros et j'aime bien l'autre
celui là tu là non celui là cela ouais
non mais c'est plusieurs jeux c'est pas
une perfusion francs sud à la battle
vous pouvez mettre vos pronostics dans
les commentaires attention ne pensais
pas que je vais réussir avant lui parce
que lui y voit tout les casse tête que
je résous est ici que je suis pas très
très bon dans ces constructions là en
plus milliards dans les boîtes les trucs
de logique et moi vite chacun est fait
on commence par lui on commence par tous
alors ah tiens c'est pour toi merci loïc
c'est à toi mais et joyeux noël
cette fois il y avait un cadeau j'ai
pourtant sur la demande et du coup
batailleur grâce j'ai eu une playstation
4 que tu m'as offert d'ailleurs ça m'a
fait vraiment vraiment plaisir ce ça
c'était vraiment je suis pas sympa le
gars bien sympa je suis un pas si c'est
un constat instagram qui te donne en
cause pour faire gagner non les cages
vraiment toi tu es arrivé le fait tient
l'école à une playstation 4 bat
d'ailleurs là je vous la met en faute au
[Rires]
qatar parce que comme moi lâché en
vacances en temps de cette vidéo avant
noël tu as vu dans quel point est ce que
tu m'as offert pas du coup de frein du
réveil club et tous ces cookies que j'ai
fait moi-même sa chair mois les
éminences un bocal et je lui ai donné
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti c'est pas ça pas le vote que
pierre d'accord nous sommes plus du tout
à quoi ça tombait à la balle mais si
c'était une étoile maintenant si je suis
plus et c'est toi qui a dit j'aimerais
trop faire des castels ouais c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai dit ouais et boum
les pop up petit haricot vert et ça
c'est au cas où il y en a un qui s'abîme
on peut leur comme ça on peut le changer
c'est dur à faire maintenant parce que
sa venue de suite mieux
pas du tout en fait moi ce que je vais
faire c'est plutôt je vais essayer de
faire des s que je vous mets les liens
dans la barre d'infos mon amant ah bah
oui mais mais leurs liens dans la barre
d'infos je pense que ça leur fait jouer
au jeu mais les biens dans la
description des roses de labarde
en fait ça ressemble à un petit passage
au modèle ouais ouais ouais voilà votre
premier cas c'est pour fabien bravo
on active sur cela ah les salaires plus
facile et irlande donc on fait déjà
qu'on le dépasse et ça c'est ma
spécialité de toi je peux le faire le
gamin va passer car si ça peut le
défaire plus rapidement que je ne peux
le refaire pajot paris c'est à dire que
qu'est-ce que paris ait finalement
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que la vie
qu'est ce que la vie est ce que l'amour
ça je te dis dis j'ai réussi c'est pour
ça que moi je vois moi pour moi le
succès et il se trouve là et c'est une
femme vidéo était une fin de vidéo j'ai
réussi j'ai dit toi tu sais bien faire
les quatre têtes l'airé de klaxons
l'état et donc tu as réussi le premier
et le deuxième c'était plutôt pour moi
et ils soutiennent qu'elle espère donc
voir des tués mais c'est pas si facile
les pompiers ont besoin de maîtres fois
on n'est pas non mais c'est pas méchant
mais c'est un peu ce pas gentil non plus
grand spa qui est de peu le brevet
situation moi je pense que la vie m'ont
dit qu'un petit bonhomme et à deux têtes
[Applaudissements]
tu vois j'avais un petit bedon
j'avais un caillou comme par hasard le
mec a bien jailli alors bon moi j'en
suis là je vois un truc qui me fait
super bad et c'est que les forces à
internet
ça me plaît pas moi je vais lagrange et
de chaudières et c'est parce que je les
mange un peu il ya la can du temps
babac bas parce que j'en sais un petit
pont et voilà mais je crois que c'est le
but de ce casse-tête ses deux consoeurs
l'équipe et on met le petit bonhomme que
le second voulait attention il va
trouver là-bas
[Applaudissements]
ah ça ressemblait à quoi vous passez un
force 3 tati seller plusieurs de la
collection c'est vrai alors ils montrent
comment le réseau tu sais quoi mais je
pense que même avec celle j'aurais du
mal
en fait c'est grâce à jamais les
explications avec des casse tête que tu
achètes peu ils ont mis avec
explications on peut essayer je propose
qu'on essaie avec l'explication masi
parce que quand je vois comme on galère
à monter un meuble
alors qu'on a payé par un casse tête etc
et un tabouret je suis pas sûr qu'on
dirait avec ce truc j'espère juste que
mien est fait exactement comme le tien
parce que sinon je l'emmerdé
moi je te le dis droit dans les yeux
loïc masi le dis moi bien de relire et
joey starr à la belle époque s'établit
entre ça alors alors finalement c'est un
peu un tuto montage peur du taux
comment résoudre un casse avec une
solution va vous le vous le fais moi
vous prenez par exemple deux petits
bouts de bois comme celui-ci prenait 4
pièces et placer les aplats de h2 sur un
plan de travail commun 10 pieds relevé
ray à 90° de manière à obtenir
vue de face le point de vue ci contre
prenez deux autres pièces à et lycées
les entre les deux arches afin qu'elle
repose en équipe sur le bad l'assemblage
quoi techniquement c'est pas si simple
quand le lis tu copies de pain non non
ensuite étape numéro 3 ça vient vigilant
qui prend du retard
prenez une nouvelle pièce à des insérées
là dans l'espace entre les pièces un à
trois et à cinq à six ça c'est des
formats de papier sage palach pas si
canal a battu lille où es tu lis tu les
ai répété l'opération à l'opposé avec
une huitième pied ça commence à fait pas
ça pourquoi moi ça fait pas sa lassitude
appels d'offres publics qui ont ensuite
90 degrés alors ça c'est lénine perdre
avec les 400
à 90° comment thomas müller s'est passé
en place l'histoire
qu'est-ce qui est ce que ça déjà ce
qu'il veut que je fasse exactement ce
cinéma allez allez oui le mec on prend
trop de l'avant mais ça c'est fait hop
90° quoi c'est là sa compo prenez les
trois dernières pièces à je dispose il
est comme illustré attendait le plus moi
je fais puisque le 3 mai 4 quel nom
c'est pas une pièce à ça ah oui ah bah
voilà
sinon je connais une anecdote il donc
mais qui alors non mais sans rire qui va
penser à dire dans sa réflexion alors
moi je vais poser mes pièces comme ça ça
va me permettre effectivement de tout
cas c'est pas moi sur mon lui peut
tourner la page c'est bon là
je comprends pas loïc ah ouais oui car
je ne compte pas je sais on a quelques
sapins aulas mais alors si je comprends
pas comment on pourrait le faire seul
donc le manque des mains comment c'est
possible
tu t'en sors ça ouais ouais carrément
ont carrément de ouf là c'est moi je
t'attends parce que j'ai pas envie de te
laisser galéré qua non mais moi
j'aimerais te dire coucou l'os même coup
le colosse cool cool cool coolos crois
qu'à un moment donné j'ai fait mes
preuves en tant qu' en tant que sales
vers toi tu faisais quoi les casse tête
tu laisses moi je les tue moi tu les
tubes avec la flèche de la patience et
et de la conviction et de la conviction
vous êtes comme un hôpital peut-être
transcender écoute
merde je pense qu'avec une notice on a
quand même tous capables de refaire un
casse-tête en 127 bis ça je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec toi non écoute moi le
casse-tête jeu j'en fais une échelle une
échelle qui nous mènera enfin surtout
toi vers le million d'abonnés
c'est beau ce que tu dis ça me touche
voilà cette échelle mais elle est
fragile
donc on compte sur vous pour la
maintenir en place c'est beau que les
intrants est fini pour écoute mais
sachez que tu as perdu le défi que j'ai
perdu le défi mais je n'ai pas gagné là
bas j'ai pas gagner le respect des gens
qui aimeraient qu'à nantes non plus mais
je n'ai pas perdu la guerre
pour autant est ce que tu veux que je te
l'offre puisque on va leur dire venez
voir offrir aux gens pour que parce que
comme on n'a pas été résolu il est
encore un peu vierge de résolution est
d'ailleurs bon surtout pas leur donner
trop laide dépasse pas le renvoyer comme
ça donc en vous mais les casquettes sur
instagram comme d'habitude vous regardez
cette photo il ya tout dans la
description de cette photo et et la
semaine prochaine je le fais gagner ce
sera une bonne résolution de bonne année
loïc merci beaucoup merci à vous on peut
vous retrouver dans mes montages ou sur
votre instagram qui s'annonce riche ici
juste là mon instinct g qui s'affiche là
de la torre pu le mettre au moins aussi
groupe le tien se révèle merci à vous
d'avoir regardé la vidéo ici je vous
mets le casse-tête de la semaine
dernière c'était euclide la joue mais
une autre vidéo qu'est sorti ce mois ci
qui était plutôt bien badass est ici
vous pouvez vous abonner à moi à très
bientôt loïc ciao ciao
[Musique]